I have to let you all know before
today's video starts that what you're
about to see got me banned from twitch
this whole thing was live streamed on my
twitch Channel and during the stream not
even after during the stream my channel
got taken down I got locked out of my
Twitch account because uh Nintendo I was
able to confirm that it wasn't Nintendo
which sent me an email saying Nintendo
was the claimant issued a dmca takedown
while I was live the claim says that
they are the copyright holders of uh the
legend of zelatias of the Kingdom
thankfully I was able to appeal it and
twitch gave me my channel back and
remove the copyright strike but Nintendo
still did take me down for what you're
about to watch so that's fun
I had a boxing match happen which meant
that I got very far behind on everything
in life in general
including
The Legend of Zelda
tears of the Kingdom so we're gonna
watch official trailer number three
which I haven't seen yet then we're
going to read some of the previews the
context
um ahead here is that I currently and
I'm so ready to eat my words feel less
excited about this than I felt about
breath of the Wild by a pretty
significant margin I have not seen
official trailer three I have not read
the previews but currently
I just don't have the same level of hype
and I think there are a number of
reasons that I feel that way I think
partly it's that I felt like breath of
the wild was so magical and it felt like
almost like a once in a lifetime game
where like I don't even feel like an
elder ring too would feel the same as
Elden ring like it's just so hard to
come off the breath of the wild at least
personally I absolutely adore it and I
yeah I feel like that sentiment is not
exclusive to me
I feel like there's been slightly less
height the second part of that which is
why I'm really excited to watch the
trailer today is that I love games that
introduce a lot of building mechanics
physics related mechanics
from an observation standpoint I really
love seeing what the community does with
things and seeing what other people
manage to create that facet of video
games has never appealed to me that much
I love Minecraft but when it comes to
Zelda
what I really want is dungeons which I
feel like people can test whether breath
of the wild even had dungeons that's Up
For Debate I feel like the Divine beasts
count as dungeons uh but I I would love
to see more dungeons more elaborate
dungeons than the Divine beasts and
again while I think that the crafting
mechanics look very cool and are so
technically impressive in terms of how
Zelda manages physics like never
did I consider you know playing zeldo
when I was six years old that they would
end up being like the Pinnacle of video
game physics yeah what they've done is
is so so so so impressive but it's just
not necessarily what I want from self I
think it's also partly that this is one
of the only Zelda games that exists on
the exact same map which is very
different it doesn't feel like a new
Hyrule that we're getting lost in
um so just it's just different so we're
gonna watch official trailer three and
then catch up on some of the previews
um this has 9.7 million views even
though it came out three weeks ago
that's a lot of the use so let's make
sure
1080 is apparently the highest quality
that they do over it uh the Nintendo of
America channel
and let's do it
I've not had anything spoiled for me I'm
excited
so far
about the same as what we've seen before
I do like that music though
link
[Music]
what will he do next
look at him go
[Music]
so I don't remember if they've addressed
full damage
well I like to look at that
[Music]
God breath of the wild was so good at
least this is making me remember that
oh
that's a hint to the dungeon right
[Music]
looks very dramatic
this is a good trailer this is a very
good trailer
[Music]
Zelda
we rely on your night and that legendary
sword he carries
our last line of defense will be link
it's a little boy
in a green tunic I'm sorry he's great
he's zero time I apologize
[Music]
the weapon
combination stuff is very cool
[Music]
what
boy got Rockets now
[Music]
whoa I know why I am here
it's something only I can do
do not look away you witness a king's
Revival and the birth of his new world
map Master Matt Mercer
dude I have
hella chills
this music
you are our final hope
okay
this is a really good trailer
link
you must find me
wow that's a good trailer I have
Goosebumps so
a couple of things it's hinted at big
bad guys in the way that previous
trailers didn't which is like taking us
away from the all of the new stuff
they've introduced I get why they had to
focus on that previously it just wasn't
necessarily what I wanted from Zelda as
impressive as it is I don't know if
we're seeing dungeons there that cart
ride could have been a dungeon but
obviously there's just less focus on
that in general all the new abilities do
look really cool the big Temple coming
out of the sand that looked awesome so
this is a very good trailer definitely
the best trailer yet I still would not
say I'm as excited as I was about breath
of the wild but I think that that's also
like the time it came out it was very
different what it did was very very
different it came on new hardware that
we didn't know the capabilities of yet
whereas now we're a little bit more
aware of the limitations that come with
the Nintendo switch the music was
beautiful that it had so much hot
um and it is really hard to sell people
on the appeal of breath of the wild
which was uh in my opinion the
exploration uh we spoke about this
earlier during the stream but I also was
a fan of weapon degradation and a lot of
people didn't like it but I like the way
it makes me think it adds an extra layer
of complexity during combat I'm a big
fan of that definitely also just
concerned about how it's gonna run
um Nintendo can do such a fantastic job
with Mario and Zelda but breath of the
wild still had a ton of frame rate drops
and I feel like gaming audiences are
only getting less accepting of that kind
of stuff less forgiving of that kind of
stuff and it does look
pretty damn big
and with the amount of
stuff you can do with the physics it's
also just I'm gonna get [__] for this
because I get it even when I say it
about uh Pokemon which seems nuts to me
like I've said it with Pokemon trailers
people give me [__] it is unfortunately
not a very good looking game
um just graphically compared to
everything else in the market art style
wise I think is beautiful and I really
like it and I love the world of breath
of the wild and getting lost in the
Wilder breath of the wild and
discovering things that you never knew
existed and just freaking out but yeah
it's it's in my opinion kind of
undeniable that the switch Hardware is
holding back games that are running on
the switch at this point and I say that
even with the switch outlet which I
really like it's uh
it's just unfortunate that for all of
the incredible Innovations the team is
obviously making and how impressive they
are technically it's just the dirt
textures you know it's just hard to
ignore that it's it's just a bummer
definitely miles ahead of scarlet and
violet don't disagree with you there
but the switch is what it is okay so we
also got since this happened
a bunch of previews came out from
different media Outlets who I believe
they flew actually a whole bunch of
people I know to New York
to check out the game
I of course was not one of them as
Nintendo does not like me allegedly
so this is from IGN it says the Legend
of Zelda tears of the Kingdom hands on
preview it lets you test out your
craziest ideas
um which I appreciate but again is not
the appeal of Zelda to me I understand
why you would show press that because
they're showing them the stuff that's
new
um but we'll see we'll see also shout
out to Brian otano oh Brian wrote it
cool
Brian is a huge Zelda fan it says it
should come as a surprise to exactly
nobody that the Legend of Zelda tears of
the kingdom is is going to be an
absolutely massive video game with a
staggering amount of things to do and
see is it too much of we do it for that
long
you can check out scallops as well
um after all it is the follow-up to The
Legend of Zelda breath of the wild one
of the biggest deepest and rewarding and
most rewarding uh open world games ever
made but what truly caught me off guard
with my time playing tears of the
Kingdom wasn't just how much there was
to do good and there certainly was tons
it was how much creative freedom I had
as far as I had as I attempted to take
on every corner of it so far which is
what I loved about breath of the wild
again I know Ryan's a big Nintendo guy
and to say that you're
caught off guard means it's leagues
ahead breath of the Wilds Court
philosophy was effectively see that
landmark in the distance you can walk
there in tears of the Kingdom it's more
like see that landmark in the distance
where you have a hundred different ways
to get there and a lot of them might not
work but when one does oh boy you're
gonna feel like a genius I hadn't really
considered that okay so because I guess
my brain had focused on how much of it
appears to be about crafting which is
something that doesn't appeal to me as
much I really hadn't considered that it
could have the exact experience that I
just had with tunic which was making you
feel really smart when you figure
something out it's a very satisfying
thing when video games pull that off
correctly if you haven't played the
witness or tunic play both of them let's
step back for a sec or should I say sore
above nice floating high above Hyrule uh
the Skylands and that's where the large
majority of my premium Taste of the
Kingdom took place yeah I guess I don't
have a concept of how big the Skylands
are either they look pretty big
and obviously that's the way that
they're refreshing the map right like
they're making this this map seem bigger
and broader for sure if the higher blow
is the updated open well for breath of
the wild which makes sense the sky
sections feel more akin to the Wind
Waker just minus the big red boat to get
around that's interesting I do love Wind
Waker you can soar through the sky on
your trusty paraglider hoping you've got
enough stamina to not only make the trip
but to scale the side of whatever you're
trying to get on top of if you've played
breath of the wild you're already
familiar with that exercise but this
time around you've got a lot more
options and that's where things get
really clever and occasionally really
funny
so I didn't
really do that much like creative
traversal in breath of the wild I don't
feel like I kind of just ran places or
rode the horse places
obviously you have to climb occasionally
and a big part of it was like getting
the stamina and then finally being able
to climb something and maybe that'll
just work in a different way now gliding
yeah we did do a lot of gliding uh this
time around you got a lot more options
and that's the thing get really clever
and occasionally really funny using some
pots lying around I decided to make a
goofy double decker bomber jet to fight
through this guy's in style I couldn't
tell you why I decided to make it a
double deck of a sides I thought it
looked cool at the moment and sometimes
really that's reason enough I'm just so
interested if that's something I will
really enjoy I don't I just don't know
yet got some screenshots it I mean it
looks exactly the same as breath of the
wild really radio Wheels object
manipulations you probably still sit the
whole whistle button by accident
[Laughter]
be able to save custom vehicles and
Contraptions it's just
it's I I'm still just not sure
all in all from ultra-handed views and
dozens of Sky Islands these are just
some of the things that make this game
the Red Direct sequel to a previous
Zelda game feel the most fresh so far
that's because lots of the animations
objects outfit sounds and more feel very
similar to breath of the wild which is
admittedly a slight letdown based on how
much of that game hinged around surprise
and discovery true
but tears of the kingdom is laid or
tiered and the way you interact with
nearly everything is evolved in creating
in dramatic ways sorry creative and
dramatic way so I have little doubt
there won't be a million new things to
do and see in the full game but now I'm
getting not to only experience it all
myself but to also see how the surely
massive player base will make and break
this game in brilliant Silly Ways and
typically that's the thing I remain very
excited about I'm really excited to see
what other people do let's check uh
someone said skill up how to good
video
scale up tears of the Kingdom thank you
12 days maybe it was sponsored by
Express shut up Ralph this video is
sponsored by expressvpn don't let me
down Ralph
tell me about the world other than just
the crafting
we have all seen the trailers and we've
all marveled at the ability of link to
MacGyver a speedboat out of some shitty
found lying around on the ground but let
me tell you you have absolutely no idea
what is in store for you when it comes
to this sandbox even based on this small
section that I have seen I cannot
believe what Nintendo have built here
this sandbox is unfucking believable the
number of things that you are able to
build
process that you go through to build
them the different ways that each of you
are I mean again exploration it's
incredibly impressive I typically cannot
fathom the mind or the minds that it
took to create all of this and I shudder
to imagine the code base that makes it
all possible in two hours I feel like I
experienced six games worth of mechanics
every new objective I encountered I
poked and prodded to see what the
sandbox could withstand and every single
time it cackled back more than able to
handle anything I threw at it the amount
of Ingenuity and experimentation that is
possible here is just out of this world
there are definitely still many it is
nuts again like how much is it just like
the gamecraft it is yeah I'm not trying
to take away from any of of how I feel
about this that this is extremely
impressive and that like we did an
episode of playlists in the video game
podcast I have about it about how
impressive it's the only word to use
Zelda's physics are
uh it's just not generally what I look
for in a Zelda game like it almost feels
like a different IP at this point you
know and that's not to say it doesn't
look good it's just different people
like different and then respond to the
complaints of breath of the wild being
too sandbox driven and not focusing
enough on the legendary
yes the grand temples and dungeons Etc
it's clear that Nintendo are definitely
doubling down on the sandbox yeah it's
unclear if they haven't also buttressed
that other side of the game as well
there are also plenty of question marks
around performance which I'll tell you
right now wasn't great and yeah it's not
a final build yada yada but we all know
the limits of the switch at this point
and tears of the Kingdom appears to be
pushing up hard against them yeah and
even with these outstanding questions
and I do wonder if um
so
Brian's preview said it was mostly
pretty consistent browse preview said
the performance was not great I do
wonder if this like them like he said
butting up against the limitations of
the switch Hardware is going to be the
thing that kind of forces Nintendo to
iterate on that Hardware frame rate's
going to be an issue 100 I totally agree
yeah it's just
it just holds the dev teams back at this
point two hours with this title has
already left me convinced that this is
not resting on breath of the Wild's
Laurels at all that's good even in this
tiny tiny window this was one of the
most flexible responsive and creative
sandboxes I've ever experienced in a
video game it's super impressive
franchise it's been around for this long
and has inspired this many different
things
is just like reiterating on open world
sandboxes though like
[Applause]
they might
even if this doesn't end up being a uh
what people want from a traditional
Legend of Zelda game I almost wouldn't
be surprised if like if I can remove
that part of my brain which I think
maybe I haven't been able to do just yet
and I'll see come Thursday if I can stop
being Luke where are the dungeons like
and I can stop thinking about it that
way it wouldn't surprise me
if Zelda managed to like soft reinvent
the sandbox genre with the amount of
creativity that everyone's talking about
being here like it's being so hyped up
by everybody who played it
um that I wonder if it's like you know
another new Benchmark after breath of
the wild already was and that is
impressive as hell considering how much
of an influence Zelda has already had on
video games as a whole even if I'm not
getting my dungeons
I don't want to take any credit away
from them regarding how impressive this
is in my own Hands-On demo I was faced
with a puzzle where I needed a log but
they weren't any around there were
however some trees but I didn't have an
ax so
I found a nearby Rock I was able to fuse
the two of those together to create an
ax at which point I could chop down a
tree
how hard it's gonna be like am I gonna
be Googling solutions for things or is
it just I feel like it's probably gonna
end up being one of those things where I
did think this kind of happened with
breath of the wild where you get stuck
and you're like I wonder if this works
and you're like oh my God it does work
so back to Crossing this Lake the
Nintendo rep built the same log raft
that ayanuma did but instead of
attaching fans to it they had some
rockets in their inventory and so that's
so silly they dropped them on the floor
picked them up with ultra so because all
of this zonai stuff is so important I
also wonder how big your inventory is
and how much Inventory management will
be a thing because it was sort of a
thing in breath of the wild you'll find
these large floating blocks they're
essentially zero buoyancy they won't
rise or fall except when something
pushes or pulls them so I get on the
first of these and I want to cross
toward another aisle and since it's
directly ahead of me I can point the
rockets in that direction and off I go
so then you just have to hit them yeah
put that angled a little bit off
later I wanted to access an aisle that
was above me so I would attach the
rockets at an angle and then that is
where I would go damn this is so
impressive like if they don't win every
technical achievement of what I'd be
sure to understand the importance of
physics in this sandbox do not imagine
that every item is programmed to go in a
specific direction oh you can move it
like while it's already in the air as
well
you know how I know that watch this
do you see the way that glider is flying
away it doesn't go in a straight line it
undulates up and down this is how
aerodynamics works if you throw a paper
plane it will do this when it loses most
of its forward propulsion God that's so
impressive they just keep doing it they
modeled the physics for how this object
what about the animals
can't do anything else I will give you
another zonite devices have stamina in
the form of Zone I charge and part of
the gameplay loopy is to steadily
increase that charge by various means so
your Contraptions can remain powered for
longer here with this dumbass flying
okay so the Zone I charge thing that um
Ralph's talking about here has got to be
how you prevent people from just being
able to like get to sections of the game
they aren't supposed to go to yet kind
of in the same way that I feel like
you're stamina bar was in breath of the
wild
um because we saw some of those
abilities where you can like rise
through the bottom of a cave and come
out on top
um so the yeah the batteries here have
got to be that means to stop us
from just being able to cross the map
and end up in a restricted area I
imagine it's just gonna slowly dull out
more charge so you can get away had it
more Zone I charge I would have been
able to stay in the air for longer but
instead my flying machine morphs from
hot air balloon into lead balloon
no fall damage at all so I learned a lot
from this foul attempt namely this thing
turns like an old tanker I'd imagine
that it would kind of turn on a dime but
this turn Arc you saw that was me hard
locking to the left oh yeah because it's
stuck on them because I don't have
anything to it plank on the back right
Point myself with the objective for the
next flight here's how that went
[Music]
foreign
because you don't have enough upward
propulsion and at the same time you
don't have any means to actually like
there's no access on this back okay okay
I'm gonna love this I take back
everything I said
that I'm so into watching Ralph solve
this problem dude you know what it's
gonna be okay if I get rid of the Zelda
part of my head if I look at this as
Co-op maybe this is a really really good
game to stream or a really good game to
play with other people in a way that I
think breath of the wild was too but
this even more so because you'll be
solving it with each other
it's
Legend of Zelda science of the kingdom
and I love that
and it's going to be really really fun
to solve these problems with a group of
people for sure thank you Ralph for that
appreciate it Shame about the switch
obviously yeah it's one of those things
where when you talk about something
being as creative as this seems to be
and obviously less of the promise of the
Zelda that we all know and love you kind
of just gotta try it before you can
really say right I'm in agreement I have
no doubt it will be a 10 out of 10 that
it will end up getting a lot of 10 out
of 10 in reviews I imagine Skillets
headlines sometime this week when his
review comes out will be something along
the lines of I'd recommend or I highly
recommend
and I do hope that this leads uh
Nintendo to improving the switch
Hardware
it's just a very different direction
very different direction that is
ultimately okay even if it's like a
direction that it's just a genre of
video game that doesn't necessarily
appeal to me as much
it's okay